mais vous qui êtes le symbole ce moment
de l'hyper robe de l'hyper pénis de
cette espèce de sexualité question très
masculine
est ce que le hashtag nitoo justement ce
qu'on est en train de traverser ne
pourrait pas un peu changé la donne ne
pourrait pas changer cette sueur
objectivation d'état déjà c'est
complètement tout ça que vous dites
c'est malheureusement pas pas vrai parce
que la pornographie de nouvelles depuis
dix ans s'est joué par les femmes si
vous et les pornostars à quel niveau se
poussent et qu'est ce qu'ils font il ya
plus longue qui domine il ya beaucoup de
nouveaux deux nouvelles séries sur
internet qui sont dédiés aux strapontins
c'est les femmes qui prend l'homme donc
c'est complètement l'inversé lumière la
première c'est la première chose qu'on
voit sur internet
c'est le lesbo dans le monde entier les
femmes et sont en train de s'organiser
chez elle ils ont presque plus besoin de
l'homme m des femmes qui font je pense
aux pays de l'est notamment où elles
sont extrêmement mal traitées elles
n'ont alors pas du tout dans un autre
monde vous venez dans le paysage si je
vous invite à bout la paix ça mon studio
à elles sont quasi tous drogués elle
fois elle se lance alors max vous savez
dit maltraités c'est une chose doré
c'est une autre on à la drogue la pala
mais je dirais à la bécasse inquiet on à
la drogue partout et donc la drogue dans
le porno est maltraité c'est pas du tout
comme ça on a des agences et je vous
dise avec le coeur je suis en train de
défendre je défends jamais mon boulot je
défends ça que je fais les jouets dit
qu'à la pornographie aujourd'hui c'est
une vraie industrie tout court les
filles vient et décide à 18 ans est
arrivé chez nous et font des castings
c'est l'interdition c'était à saison est
arrivé à saison je voudrais je vous
rassure 9 sur 17 des 18 ans qui arrive
et il n'y a pas de maquereaux derrière